I want to take up in volume 13, December 18, 1921, and the theme here is that peace
is the springtime for the soul. So to start us off I want to give you Isaiah 26 verse 3.
You will keep him in perfect peace whose mind is stayed on you because he trusts in you.
So that's actually the theme we're actually going to be dealing with and it's expressed
very well by Isaiah there in chapter 26 verse 3. So Louisa Sedg was feeling very oppressed because
of the privation of Jesus and when he eventually came he began speaking to her about peace.
My daughter he said what is it? Because she's been having trouble waiting for him. I see a mood
and a shadow in you that render you dissimilar from me. I think that's a very important point
that he can find moods in us that are very unlike him. That's our disturbance about whatever we're
disturbed about and he doesn't want that he's been telling us since volume one that he absolutely
does not want any disturbance in the depths of our being, not at all. So I see a mood and a shadow
in you which render you dissimilar from me and it breaks the current of beatitude or happiness
which has almost always existed between me and you. Now considering all that Louisa has been through
from volume one to where we're at now in volume 13 it is totally amazing that Jesus tells her
that the current of happiness has almost never been broken between them. That means that she has
the peace that passes all understanding and guards the heart and the mind in Christ Jesus.
That's Philippians 4-7. Everything is peace in me he says. Therefore I do not tolerate in you even
one shadow which may shade your soul. Peace is the springtime of the soul. All virtues bloom
in peace they all grow and smile like plants and flowers at the rays of the sun in springtime
which disposes all things of nature to produce each one its own particular fruit.
If it wasn't for the spring which shakes the plants from the torpor of cold with its enchanting
smile the clothes and clothes the earth with a flowery mantle that calls everyone to admire it
with its sweet enchantment the earth would be a horrid it would be a horrid place and the plants
would end up just withering. What would we do without the wonderful green carpet that's upon
the earth and the 40 shades of green that we find in all of the plants and then the extraordinary
full range of color that we find in the flowers. There would be nothing out there to attract our
attention. So Jesus said peace is the divine smile. Now here is another major key for us to discern
where we are at in the divine will. Peace is the divine smile which shakes the soul from its torpor
like celestial springtime it shakes the soul from the cold of its passions from weaknesses
from thoughtlessness and from all the other stuff and with its smile it makes all flowers bloom
more than a flowery field and it makes all plants grow through which the celestial farmer is pleased
to stroll to pick the fruits to make them for his food. Therefore the peaceful soul is my garden
in which I enjoy and amuse myself he says. So he needs us to have peace so that even he can come to
us because he is peace Isaiah 9 chapter 6 declared that he was the prince of peace. On the day he
was born the angels proclaimed him as the king of peace. So let me give you a few
a few I should say many references. I want to give you John 14 27 the peace I give you is not the
peace that the world gives its heavenly beatitude. John 16 33 again it's not the peace of the world
that I give you it's this heavenly beatitude. John 20 verse 19 1 Corinthians 1 3 1 Corinthians 7 15
Ephesians 2 14 and so on and so forth and we're going to read that Jesus is peace. Peace is light
Jesus is light therefore peace is light therefore peace is our experience of God in us.
Let me also give you Acts chapter 10 verse 36 Romans 1 7 Romans 3 17 Romans 5 1 Romans 8 6
Romans 10 15 Romans 14 17 Romans 15 33 and the beginning of all the letters in the New Testament
that the God of peace or the peace of God would be with us. Okay so the gift of peace is all over
the New Testament the king of peace came to give us his own peace so if he finds us on peaceful
then there is that dissimilarity between us and him which he's not able to take he wants us to be
like him so he goes on and he tells Louisa peace is light and everything that the soul thinks
says and does is light that she emanates now this light is God himself moving in us and through us
and out of us to others and again I must give you Matthew 5 14 there because he tells us that
we are meant to be the light of the world but we can't have it if we don't have his peace
raining and dominating in us and therefore it's that peaceful light that goes out to give life to
everything else. Peace is light and everything that the soul thinks says and does is light that
she emanates and the enemy cannot get close to her because he feels struck wounded and dazzled
by this light now that light is God and it's the divine will operating in us and through us
and he is forced to flee so as not to get blinded so you can see therefore why Jesus wants this
peace established in us and he wants it never ever to shift because the more this peace reigns in us
the less the demon can get near us we have total protection and that's why he says in the next
paragraph peace is dominion it's raining you rain not only over yourself but also over others
so before a peaceful soul everyone remains either conquered confused or humiliated
because the peaceful soul is in a position that none of the others are in and the light of God is
coming from you through you to all the others and depending on their disposition vis-a-vis
the presence of God they will either be conquered confused or blinded or humiliated as the Lord says
therefore the other people let themselves be dominated remaining as friends or they go away
confused unable to sustain the dignity and the imperturbability and the sweetness of a soul
who possesses peace now I love that imperturbability now I know it's a big word I know it's a big word
but it means that the sign of God's presence is actually there in you no matter what is going on
in the universe no matter what is going on in the universe God is peace personified
and if we have the divine will absolutely registered raining permanently in us well that peace that
passes all understanding is in us as well now as we go towards that point of complete surrender the
peace in us grows and grows and grows and grows just as the more you pull back the curtains or
lift the blinds in the morning time the more you pull back the curtains or lift the blinds in the
morning time the more the light enters the room and so the level of peace that we have is actually
one of the signs of discernment for us peace is dominion not only over oneself but also over
others so before a peaceful soul they all remain either conquered confused or humiliated
therefore they either let themselves be dominated remaining as friends or they leave confused
unable to sustain the dignity and the imperturbability the sweetness of a soul who possesses peace
now what that reminds me of is Mactimilian Colby
on the day he offered his life for a man he didn't know there was shocking fear in the place fear
was raining because the enemy uses fear all the time to dominate us and since a prisoner had escaped
the guards were going to kill 10 others to make sure that nobody else would escape
and so everybody was in mortal fear and as the the men were arbitrarily chosen out of the crowd
one of the men cried out about his wife and children
and immediately Mactimilian Colby stepped forward and he said excuse me that man has a wife and
children I am a priest I don't have a family I will go instead of him and the survivors of the camp
said that at that moment fear went into the guards
and came out of the prisoners and the guards were really terrified they could not believe
that this very peaceful serene person was imperturbable in the face of death and the horrible
deaths that they were able to give people so they said that for a few moments there was total silence
complete silence until the commander got his breath back and ordered him to stand in line
but the survivors also said that as a result of this act of extraordinary freedom this act of
extraordinary divine love that this man made and this extraordinary sign of peace and sweetness
that the camp was never ever so bad again that one act of Mactimilian Colby changed everything
and this is the thing that we need to understand about divine acts they do change everything
we're making a real difference
even the most perverted people feel the power that the soul containing this peace has and that's
exactly the story I've told you about Auschwitz this is why I'd lorry so much and having myself
called the god of peace and the prince of peace so that's Isaiah nine six and it's Luke chapter
two as well where Jesus was proclaimed as the prince of peace there is no peace without me now
what politicians and governments and countries call peace is merely a cessation of hostilities
and it's merely a case of having arrived at a point where they can all sort of coexist
while hating each other all wanting the same things for the same reason but all wanting to have
everything and dominating everybody else that's not peace there's nothing to do with it
Jesus says there's no peace without me I alone possess it and I give it to my children that's what
he said in John 14 27 I give you my peace it's his gift to us and it's not the world's peace he said
that I give you I give you my peace that means that you will be in a relationship of union of love with
God a relationship of a correct relationship with yourself and a relationship of love to your neighbor
and I suppose a correct relationship to yourself is loving yourself properly as well so it's all love
and Jesus said there's no peace without me I alone possess it and I give it to my children
as legitimate children who remain bound as heirs to all my goods now the legitimate children are
Romans 8 19 the children are through whom God can restore the whole earth
and so he continues the world and creatures do not have this peace
and what is not possessed cannot be given we can only give what we have at the most they can give
an apparent peace which torments them inside it is a false peace and it contains a poisonous
sip within it and this poison puts the remorse of conscience to sleep and it leads one into the
kingdom of vice well we have far too much evidence about that in world politics
therefore I am true peace Jesus says I want to conceal you within my peace
so that you may never be disturbed and that the shadow of my peace like dazzling light
may keep far away from you anything or anyone who might even shadow your peace
that peace that passes all understanding that Jesus is talking about here
like a dazzling light that is to experience paradise on earth
paradise on earth this is it that's what everybody wants but they just don't want it God's way
so let's come to december 22 1921 and here we're talking about the motivation
that we have in doing everything and Jesus says that the only acceptable motivation
for all our thoughts words actions everything is love and it's love for him
in other words our entire relationship with God is a relationship of love
so this is a very important message about motivation continuing in my usual state my beloved Jesus
made himself seen within a dazzling light now you know that that dazzling light is the divine will
you know that it is peace you know that it is love you know that it is grace and he said in
volumes one and two that he is faith he is hope he is charity okay so this dazzling light is all
of those things he showed himself within a dazzling light and this light melting into a rain of light
rained down upon souls isn't that absolutely glorious however many did not receive this current of light
being as though closed and the current ran wherever it found souls open to receive it
now if you have ever watched a stream becoming a river you'll see that the water will flow
wherever it's allowed to flow if there are rocks in the way then the water has to go around the rocks
if it comes to a dead end it has to stop but then it will find some other way to get out
and so when the rain of this divine light comes down upon souls it doesn't always have the freedom
to move and sometimes it has to meander around like the river finding its way
the current ran wherever it found souls open to receive it just like the water will and the light
that comes to us even from the sun will go anywhere that you don't block it from going
my daughter jesus said the current of my grace which is this rain of light
enters into souls who operate out of pure love now here's the secret of the saints
and it mightn't be any harm to put that as a heading
how do you get a sanctity quickly and that is to operate out of pure love now you have heard
me say this many times before that saint there is of this you said that if you pick a pin off the
floor out of pure love for god it is worth all the projects that people can do on the planet
from their own will the motivation is everything it's not just why that you do it it's why you do it
you even come across this when you listen to the news media saying that a murder has taken place
but they haven't yet found the motive and they're not satisfied until they find why this happened
and when they find the motive for the murder then they can they can actually solve the mystery
and jesus is coming straight into the center of everything the real issue is why you're doing
something and he's looking for the motive from us as well he says the current of my grace enters
into souls who operate out of pure love now notice pure love impure love is there's a bit of self
in it there's something for me that's impure i'm not really really loving god i'm not really serving
him behind it all i'm serving myself an impure motive for example would be that i tell myself or you
that i'm going to fast tomorrow and fasting is a good thing but in the back of my mind i say well
i could lose a few pounds you know there's the impure motive i'm not really doing it for god
i'm really doing it in the hopes that i lose a few pounds weight
sad but unfortunately that's like us the current of my great my grace enters into souls who operate
out of pure love only the motive of loving me keeps souls open to receiving the current of my
graces now there you've got the answer to the question what closes people off from receiving
grace and what opens them up to receiving grace those who love him will be open to him those who
don't love him will be close to him that tells you how many are close to him which is very very sad
jesus says i am love and of course anybody who doesn't love love is outside of the thing i mean
i can't remember what saint i'm oh i do remember now it's saint Francis of his sissy used to say
at the end of his days love is not loved love is not loved and people were wondering what he was
talking about so in order for us to truly be able to enter fully into what god is offering us we
have to become love and then the little flame of love in us leaps into the fire of love that he is
and we become part of him and he becomes part of us we possess god and he possesses us i am love
he says and they are love so they are in continuous currents for me and i for them so the continuous
currents is this continuous traffic that's going on between us and him so if you think of john one
51 just for a moment and the the ladder that connects heaven and earth and the angels of god
going up and down this ladder and jesus said he was the fulfillment of that he is the ladder he
is the connection between heaven and earth and he says that the traffic that's going up and down
this ladder is love love coming from him to us and love coming from us back to him responding
and completing the cycle so there's continuous movements of this love between us and him
on the other hand those who operate with the human purpose are closed to me so here's the human will
and they um me me me stuff they're closed to me he said their current is open to all that is human
so they receive the current of what is human and the frightening thing is
that you can have people men and women wearing beautiful religious habits living a completely
human life to me that's otter tragedy they've all the circumstances in which to live a divine life
but they can be living a completely human life one who operates with the purpose of sinning
receives the current of guilt now we've moved down much further so we've moved from the high place of
love to the middle place of the merely human and now we've moved into the low place of the area of sin
and so one who um who operates with the purpose of sinning receives the current of guilt and the
one who operates with the diabolical purpose receives the current of hell there's the lowest
place of all so the purpose or the motive in operating gives man many different tints
so we have to look at why i'm doing it and we have to look at it with with a radical honesty
so that if there is something in why i'm doing things and they're not really for god
then we've got to let it go we've got to let go and let god
the motive in operating gives man many different tints it transforms him into beautiful or into
ugly into light or into darkness into sanctity or into sin whatever the motives are in operating
that is who you are wow now we've got wonderful discernment here if i operate in love i am love
if i operate in selfishness i am selfish there you have it if i operate in sin i am sin
you are according to your motivations the book of proverbs puts it slightly differently it says
as a man thinks so is he because you see your motivations will come through your thoughts
therefore jesus says my current of love and grace and everything does not enter into everyone
and since it is rejected by the souls who are closed to me it unloads itself more mightily
and more abundantly on the souls who are open and the ones who are fully open can receive
the full tsunami of his grace that's what we have to get to being completely 100% open to him
and so after this jesus disappeared and later on he came back to louisa and he continued
would you be able to tell me why this sun illuminates the whole earth he said he's treated this before
many times because it's much larger than the earth and since it is bigger it has the capacity
of covering with its light the whole circumference of the earth which is smaller if it were smaller
it would illuminate only part of it but not all of it therefore smaller things are enveloped
and absorbed by bigger things that that's the point that he wants to make smaller things
are taken up and absorbed by bigger things so if my little love is put into the furnace of his love
the smaller thing is taken up and absorbed into the bigger one now my will is the greatest of all
virtues he says i'm surprised at him calling it a virtue therefore all virtues must remain shrunken
and dissolved within my will even more before the power of the sanctity of my will
the other virtues tremble out of reverence for my will and if without my will virtues
think of doing something great at the contact with my sanctity and power of the virtue of my will
they realize they've done nothing this you john 15 5 again without me you can do nothing you may
appear great in the eyes of the world and in order to give them the mark of virtues i am forced to
plunge them into the immense sea of my will not only has my will primacy overall but it gives
the different tints of beauty to all the virtues it places on them the divine tints the celestial
glaze and the dazzling light therefore if the virtues are not covered by my will they may be good
but they're not beautiful they're not beautiful with that beauty that in raptures in chants and
enamours both heaven and earth it's too small too confined to human too ordinary
afterwards jesus transported louisa outside of herself and he showed her many channels of water
were opening under the sea which making their way underground inundated the fountains of foundations
of cities i want to give you a mass three seven here the lord never does anything without telling
his prophets first now the lord gives louisa an explanation that i find utterly amazing we know
that there is a water table under the surface of the earth if there wasn't you'd have no wells
you'd have no sources of water underneath the earth and people from the time
alvedam have dug wells to find water okay so there's a water table underneath so watch this
the lord transported me
the lord transported me outside of myself and showed me how channels of water were opening
under the sea now that's not where you would expect the channels of water to be
and they were making their way underground and they were going to inundate whole cities
that's incredible i don't know if that has ever happened that's just my ignorance now
all i know is about tsunamis in other words the ocean coming in on top of cities
and at some place she said buildings collapsed somewhere else they made them disappear altogether
as these chasms of water opened and swallowed them into the earth
wow when you go back to the book of exodus and the story of moses trying to
be a goal between god and the chosen people to try and turn them into a people of god
there were several revolts against moses and erin and in one of them there were two men
called dathan and abiram and they really thought that they had just as much right as moses and erin
to offer their holy incense in the presence of god they managed to get the people in revolt
against moses and erin and god dealt with it very summarily and he didn't tell moses in the beginning
what was going to happen only he only told him step by step it's very interesting to read the story
and the final step was when moses said to the people step back from the house of dathan and the
house of abiram step step back he said step back quickly step back because the earth is going to
open up and swallow them and it did now looking at that incident in the exodus we know that that
was miraculous but from where we're standing from understanding the divine will we know that if god
says i wanted that's it it happens so here louisa is saying that god is going to allow this to happen
on the earth at some point and all afflicted he said man doesn't want to stop it now how would man
stop they they the waters of the earth from inundating cities the only way is through repentance
the only way to stop this epidemic is through repentance
man does not want to stop what he said and my justice is forced to strike him many are the cities
which will be struck by water by fire and by earthquakes now since the year 2000 we're getting
used to a whole area is being struck by fire and we watched them in absolute amazement
we're all to getting used to the earthquakes we seem to think that earthquakes are normal
does anybody know that they keep on increasing
i remember just before the year 2000 coming across a little piece in a newspaper
which said that for every decade of the 20th century particularly in america that the
chastisements the the natural disasters increased in number and in ferocity for every single decade
of the 20th century did they get the message no so louisa said to jesus my love what are you saying
you won't do this and she said i wanted to intercede with him but he disappeared that
means he doesn't want to know i'm just letting you know this is going to happen i don't want you to
just stop it so december the 23rd 1921 one who operates and lives in the divine will gives jesus
the field to issue new works new love and new power this is fantastic
so jesus said to louisa daughter of my volition we now know she's been over 32 years in the divine
will as you operate and live in my will you make more new acts come out from within my will
now why are they new it's because a creature is doing them for the first time
and so god incorporates that and you give me the field for new works new love and new power
how happy i feel that the creature by living in my will gives me the field to act
on the other hand one who does not live in my will folds my arms and renders my will useless for her
his will is not useless for anybody else but if we don't do this yes one who does not live in my will
folds my arms and renders my will useless for her all of us want to do something
for the human race we see it in such dire straits and jesus says you know what to do
you open up to the divine will you let the divine will operate in you and through you it's fantastic
on the other hand one who does not live in my will folds my arms and renders my will
useless for her while my being is led to motion and to work by the irresistible force of my love
god is love one john four seven sam one four five verse seventeen god only ever acts out of love
how does love live love lives by giving so you need to write that down love lives by giving
by giving everything it's not really love if you hold something back that's why in marriage you have
to give everything love lives by giving and when love is not given an outlet to sacrifice itself
and to give itself love is completely frustrated and that's why it's one of the reasons why god
gives you a child that demands everything from you absolutely everything things you didn't even
know you had because the love becomes creative my being he said is led to motion and to work
by the irresistible force of my love only one who lives in my will gives me this free field
a free field is that you give him the space to work and i animate even the tiniest acts of my
divine will now if we fuse ourselves all of us in all of him all the time then the tiniest thing
even moving your head turning around looking blinking your eyes everything the tiniest thing
is animated by him it's fantastic and i do not disdain to place the seal of divine power even on
the lolliest things like i give you an example of walking sleeping thinking desiring praying
everything this is why i love so much one who lives in my will and i surround each of her acts
with so much grace with such dignity and decorum because i want the honor and the glory of my divine
work therefore be attentive and think well that if all that you do you do not do in my will you will
give uselessness to your Jesus you won't give him a chance to let his love pour out if you knew how
idleness weighs on me he said how it saddens me wouldn't you be more attentive wouldn't you respond
better and then after this louisa said i was about to close my eyes to sleep and i said to myself
oh my sleep too in your will Jesus even more may my breath be transformed into yours
so that what Jesus did while sleeping i may do as well there's a beautiful little good night Jesus
prayer beautiful but then did my Jesus sleep she asks and Jesus came back and explained
my daughter my sleep was extremely brief you see he was god as well as man
he did not have our emotional and physical and mental problems he did not have the the pressures
as we experienced them some of the saints have also slept very little and they use the hours of the
night for their resting in god but we who need our night sleep can now rest in god completely
in the divine will but he said i did sleep because Jesus wanted to do everything that human beings
should do and we have to sleep but he said i did not sleep for myself i slept for them
everything was for them and this shows you the extraordinary love that's given to us
as the head he said that means as the second atom i represented the whole human family
and i had to lay my humanity over all in order to give them rest so
he's allowing himself this physical sleep but what he wants to do is to lay his humanity
over all creatures who would ever live past present and future so that we could rest in the spirit
that we would reach this point of rest now at this point of rest is spoken about in the letter
to the Hebrews in chapter four and it's actually very important to read it
because he one of the things he says was that the people of god in the old testament didn't actually
find rest and so rest has been opened up to us in the new testament and much more especially
in the divine will
i could see he said that all creatures i could see all creatures covered with a mantle of disturbance
of struggle of restlessness now you see where he's going with trying to give them rest
and you remember Matthew 11 28 to 30 come to me and i will give you rest and i could see that
all souls were covered with a mantle of disturbance struggle and restlessness
some were falling into sin and remains saddened some were dominated by tyrannical passions
which they wanted to conquer and remain disturbed some wanted to do good
and struggled in order to do it in other words there was no peace because true peace is possessed
when the will of the person returns into the will of its creator that's where you find peace
when our will goes back into his that's when the struggle stops
outside of the center dislocated from its origin there is no peace therefore while sleeping
my humanity laid itself overall wrapping them as though within a mantle just like the hen
that's Luke 13 34 just like the hen when it calls its chicks under its maternal wings
to make them sleep in the same way extending over all i called all of my children under my wings
to give some forgiveness of sin to some victory over their passions and to some
strengthen the fight to give peace and rest to everyone and in order not to strike fear in them
but to give them courage i did this while i was sleeping i think that's absolutely gorgeous
i think that's absolutely magnificent his gentleness his delicacy
it's just amazing just like a parent would do anything not to frighten a little child
and so they they will operate very quietly if the child needs to sleep it's beautiful
i did it while i was sleeping he said who would fear someone who is sleeping
now the world hasn't changed unfortunately rather it has more struggles than ever before
and therefore i want someone who sleeps in my will you see sin hasn't decreased it has
multiplied the earth is sunk into vice that i don't know if it has ever been this bad before
and the reason why i say that is not that others wouldn't have committed the same sins
but now it's global it's not confined to one area or one country or one tribe
or one people it's actually global that's why i think it's worse
sotam and gomara is no longer just two little cities near the dead sea it's worldwide
and he wants others to sleep in the divine will now but i think it's fantastic
therefore i want someone who sleeps in my will so as to repeat the effects of the sleep of my
humanity so when we go to bed and sleep in the divine will we're sleeping with his sleep and
therefore he is continuing to do that wonder of of helping humanity to find rest
isn't that wonderful to be saving the world while you're sleeping
and then with an afflicted tone he said my other children where are they
why don't they all come to me to receive rest and peace so that's your Matthew 11 28 again
uh let us call them let us call them together he said and it seems that jesus would call them by name
one by one now that's john 10 versus two to five i know my sheep i'm the good shepherd
i call each one of them by name but few actually here and fewer still respond
so let's go to december the 25th 1921 how the humanity of jesus was nourished by his will
and the souls who live in the divine will surrounded and consoled jesus at his birth
so louisa said as i was in my usual state my sweet jesus made himself seen as a little baby
all numb with cold and throwing himself into my arms he told me what cold what cold
warm me for pity's sake do not let me freeze anymore i pressed him to my heart telling him
in my heart i possess your will and its heat is more than sufficient to warm you and jesus
all content said my daughter my will does contain everything and one who possesses the divine will
can give me everything this is extremely important
those who possess the divine will can give me everything my will was everything for me
you know that john's gospel is full of jesus's statements about the will of the father let me
give you john 5 30 john 6 40 john 7 16 john 8 28 and 29 john 10 29 and 38 john 12 49 and 50
and john 14 31 it's full of statements about my food is to do the will of the father is in chapter
john 4 34 and starting there it goes on right through its magnificent my will was everything
for me he said it conceived me it formed me it made me grow it made me be born if my mother
contributed to giving me the blood she could do so because she contained my will absorbed
within her had she not possessed my will she could not have contributed to forming my humanity
why because nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of god that's Hebrews 12 14 that you
know of my heart by now therefore my direct will now that's the will of the three divine persons
and my will which was absorbed within my mother gave me life
in other words the blessed Trinity said I want it that's it
that which is human had no power over me do you remember that jesus said that in john 19
to pilot you would have no power over me if it wasn't given to you from above
so if the divine will had not permitted you to be in this place in this job right now
you would have nothing to do with me nothing whatever that which is human had no power over me
it could give me nothing naturally a creature could give nothing to the creator
only the divine will nourished me and its breath with its breath that's the holy spirit and delivered
me to the light now we know from discoveries that were made by Ron Wyatt and you'll find his stuff
on youtube if you want Ron Wyatt has gone back to god some years ago that he found drops of the
blood of jesus in the place at calvary where the the cross was put into the hole he actually
found the hole where the cross was put and there was still some blood there and he had it analyzed
and the extraordinary thing is that he insisted on the scientists in israel examining it
he did not tell them what it was but he told them it was an extremely important thing and they were
to treat it with the utmost caution when he went back to inquire they said who owns this blood
he said what do you mean he said it they said it's alive this blood is alive that's what scientists
have discovered when they have examined blood stains on the holy eucharist as well they've
said this blood is alive and not only that they said there's only one set of chromosomes
everybody has to have two sets of chromosomes one from the male and one from the female
and Ron Wyatt said to them and he was speaking to jews who were not christians he said
that's the blood of your messiah he told you that god was his father
he got an absolutely massive reaction from them crying and weeping and everything
jesus said that it was only the divine will that nourished him was his very breath
and delivered him to the light because we know that he was born miraculously he was not born
in the way all others are born but do you think that it was the cold of the air that made me freeze
because if it was the cold of the air then you'd worry that blessed mother and joseph hadn't taken
care of him properly and hadn't dropped wrapped him in swaddling clothes they did absolutely
everything for him that they could do so the freezing and the cold that he's talking about
is now physical and oh he said it was the cold of the hearts that made me grow numb it was the
ingratitude that made me cry bitterly and my very first coming out into the light my beloved mother
soothed my crying although she too cried our tears blended together and exchanging the first kisses
we poured ourselves out in love to each other understood but our life was to be sorrow and crying
from the cradle to the grave our life was to be sorrow and crying so i had her place me in the
manger to go back to crying calling my children with my sobs and with my tears so here you have
jesus interceding for souls and he only just out of his mother's womb interceding in the crib
if only we would tell children the truth they would all be saints every one of them
so i had her place me in a manger to go back to crying calling my children with my sobs and with
my tears i wanted to move them to pity with my tears and with my mons so as to be listened to
surely you would listen to an infant but do you know who was the first after my mother
whom i called with my tears to be close to me in my very manger to pour myself out in love
he said it was you louisa because we only look at things on a material level we have to understand
that he's god and everything in the divine will is just one single point does neither pass
nor future in it everything is present so he said i called you louisa the little daughter of my will
you were so little as to surpass my dear mother in littleness so much so that i was able to keep
you near me in my own manger now when you listen to her meditations elsewhere on the the um
time of jesus in his mother's womb anti-spirth she talks about getting into the manger
she even talks about getting into the womb beside jesus i was able to keep you near me
in my own manger and i could pour my tears into your heart these tears sealed my will in you and
constituted you the legitimate daughter of my will this year's roman's eight nineteen again
at my heart rejoiced in seeing what my will had delivered in creation coming back to you
as whole in my will this was important and indispensable for me at my very first coming out to the light
of this world i was to restore the rights of creation and receive the glory as if the creature
had never departed from my will therefore the first kiss and the first gifts of my tenderest age
were for you and i just say what love what incredible love to any of us know god
it's just utterly amazing so louisa said my love how could this be if at that time i didn't even
exist and so here's the answer jesus said in my will everything existed and all things were one
single point for me this is the singularity this is the utter unbelievable simplicity of god
so all of us have been known and loved eternally no wonder he said in jeremaia 31 3 i have loved
you with an everlasting love and i am constant in my affection for you we've been loved eternally
we weren't just loved on the cross we weren't just loved during the the adult life of jesus
we've been loved eternally he went through the whole process of incarnation because of us
it's a it's a terrifying mystery in my will everything existed and all things were one single
point for me i could see you then just as i see you now and jesus also says he saw us all from the cross
and all the graces i've given you are nothing other than the confirmation of what you had been
given fab eternal from all eternity isn't that amazing and i could see not only you but in you i
saw my little divine will family which would live in my will so through louise who was to open up
this whole kingdom of the divine will he could see all of us who would follow her how content i felt
he said these suited my crying warmed me and surrounded me like a crown and defended me from
the perfect of other creatures the perfect is the absolute refusal to even acknowledge that he exists
so louise louise said she remained pensive and doubtful and jesus said what you doubted
i've told you nothing yet about the relations which exist between me and the soul who lives in my will
we are only on volume 13 when we get to volume 18 we'll be halfway there so he's right in saying
i've told you nothing yet for now i will tell you that my humanity lived from the continuous
outpouring of the divine will had i taken even one breath which was not animated by the divine
will it would have been as though degrading and disenobling for myself the soul who lives in my will
is the closest to me what do you think holiness is only closeness to god and in everything that my
humanity did and suffered she is the first among all to receive the fruits and the effects that it
contains and i have met you 1930 there so the soul who lives in the divine will is first among all of
course because if all the others are either living in the human will or even worse of course you're
first that means you're ahead of them but you have to be first in love and you have to be first in
self-sacrifice and you have to be first in encompassing all the others to bring them to him
because love is not satisfied with just having it by itself it wants all the others as well so i'm
good to stop there for now